jury RTL le Figaro LCI Olivier boste
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
grand jury bonjour François Bayrou
bonjour vous êtes le président du MoDem
et au commissaire au Plan merci d'être
avec nous faut jamais oublier pardon et
maire de pauvre effectivement vous avez
raison on en parlera peut-être
d'ailleurs la réforme des retraites
continue son chemin chaotique au
Parlement y aura-t-il une majorité pour
la voté la semaine prochaine une
adoption sans vote marquerait-elle
l'échec du gouvernement et d'ilisabeth
borne en particulier vous nous direz
tout ça François Bayrou vous qui
n'excluez rien pour la prochaine
présidentielle ce grand jury est en
direct pour poser vos questions à
François Bayrou pendant toute l'émission
C'est sur les réseaux sociaux que ça se
passe avec le hashtag le Grand Jury
Marie pierradate de la rédaction de RTL
nous alertera avec ce signal pour
relayer vos interpellations et puis pour
vous interroger à mes côtés Marion
Mourgue du Figaro et Marie chanterait
pour TF1 L avant de revenir sur le
parcours de la réforme des retraites au
Parlement un mot tout d'abord sur les
manifestations d'hier Marie chanter ou
un
million stand en France selon la CGT
hier un peu moins de 400 000 selon le
ministère de l'intérieur par
l'auriez-vous des soufflements de ce
mouvement et en tant que membre de la
majorité vous réjouissez-vous finalement
de ces chiffres d'hier
non parce que je la seule chose dont on
devrait se réjouir c'est d'une meilleure
compréhension d'une compréhension
grandissante de la réforme par l'opinion
j'espère qu'on y sera on n'y est pas
encore les chiffres en effet et donc en
revanche
c'est évident que pour les organisateurs
de manifestation c'est une déception
parce que c'est un fléchissement notable
on parlait tout à l'heure avant d'entrer
dans le studio des chiffres précis à Pau
c'est à peu près entre 3 et 4 fois moins
que les manifestations les plus
importantes les trois manifestations les
plus importantes précédentes donc ça
signifie que
l'opinion de se reconnaît pas non plus
plus complètement dans la contestation
par manifestation on va dire ça comme ça
et vous y voyez classique envoyer un
tournant hier dans cette
je veux pas je veux je voudrais
m'exprimer sans blesser les gens qui de
bonne foi
simplement parce que je crois ils n'ont
pas eu tous les éléments de
l'analyse et de l'appréciation je
voudrais m'exprimer sans être
désagréable ou
condescendant à leur endroit c'est pas
du tout mon état d'esprit je vous ai dit
que pour moi le le l'important c'était
de mesurer et de voir croître l'adhésion
à une réforme aussi importante aussi
nécessaire et aussi urgente que celle là
selon le tout dernier sondage ou donc ça
pour Le Figaro 57% des Français veulent
que cette mobilisation se poursuive
alors que vous craignez que justement
les mouvements s'installe et ce que vous
craignez aussi une radicalisation de ces
mouvements sociaux j'espère que non et
je ne n'en vois pas de signes ce qui
s'est ce qui s'est passé dans dans le
mois et demi de manifestations que nous
avons rencontré était au contraire très
maîtrisé et j'allais dire si vite même
quand vous voyez par exemple même si on
peut être en désaccord alors les
blocages c'est autre chose et il y a il
est vrai des des coupures de courant
arbitraire qui sont pas acceptables
atteinte
pour tous ceux qui veulent circuler qui
ont besoin pour leur famille qui ont
besoin d'aller
à des à des cours ou à des examens aussi
les politiques et soutiennent la réforme
et
j'ajoute que ce qui se passe avec la
grève des éboueurs à Paris est
pure simplement insupportable pour un
pays comme le nôtre on peut pas laisser
croître des montagnes d'ordures dans les
rues de la capitale de la France donc
chacun va devoir réfléchir et réfléchir
à sa part de responsabilité dans cette
affaire mais vous demandez au
gouvernement par exemple sur la question
des poubelles précisément à Paris qui
est effectivement un sujet préoccupant
une intervention des réquisitions je
pense que s'il faut prendre des
responsabilités des décisions qui soient
de cet ordre là
les Français et les Parisiens et tous
les visiteurs peuvent pas accepter
l'idée que Paris soit envahi par des
montagnes d'ordures je sais bien que
alors que tout le monde ait le droit de
manifester que tout le monde ait le
droit de faire grève oui mais le blocage
de long terme qui fait que la vie
devient invivable pour les
bien pour vous avez bien vu les images
que vous avez diffusées pour les
restaurants pour pour moi c'est
pour moi qui suis éminemment soucieux du
droit de manifester son opinion et du
droit de grève cette démarche de blocage
sans fin sans terme rend impossible la
vie en commun les leaders syndicaux y
compris à la CFDT mettent en garde
contre une violence qui pourrait
s'installer en disant si vous ne vous si
nous ne sommes pas entendus on ne pourra
plus contrôler le mouvement et ce sera
entre guillemets ingérable et très
violent ça vous l'entendez aujourd'hui
cet appel bon j'entends ce qu'on dit
mais pour moi ça n'est absolument pas la
réalité de ce que nous vivons
si je devrais si je devais faire le
point aujourd'hui sur
l'appréhension par l'opinion de la
retraite j'ai un regret que j'ai exprimé
tout au long de de cette période
c'est qu'on n'est pas donné aux Français
la vraie situation les vrais éléments de
jugement de
des régimes de retraite
ce qui se passe c'est ceci on a
constamment repris un chiffre
hypothétique potentiel pour l'avenir qui
serait de une dizaine une douzaine une
quinzaine de milliards d'euros pour dans
10 ans qu'il faudrait ajouter aux
retraites mais la vérité devant laquelle
nous devrions être révolté
tous
les parents les enfants les plus jeunes
c'est que d'ores et déjà à l'heure
actuelle et nous avons établi le chiffre
avec
une analyse du plan d'ores et déjà à
l'heure actuelle on est obligé l'État
est obligé le contribuable est obligé
d'apporter tous les ans entre 30 et 40
milliards d'euros pour compenser les
déficits de régime de retraite et alors
donc ça veut déjà dire qu'on est plus
dans la répartition on dit on dit
j'entends dire on sauve le régime par
répartition le régime para répartition
il couvre les deux tiers des besoins des
régimes de retraite puis il y a un tiers
qui est couvert
on reviendra sur
cette idée est centrale
donc plusieurs dizaines de milliards
entre 30 et 40
tous les ans pour équilibrer les régimes
de retraite
et c'est l'état le contribuable qui les
apporte
au moins
[Musique]
or
cet argent là cet argent public
si nous l'avions
ça pourrait se discuter on pourrait tout
à fait considérer il y a même eu
du temps de Churchill en Angleterre un
projet pour que ce soit l'état qui paie
les retraites qu'on appelle beveridges
pour les spécialistes du du système donc
ça pourrait discuter mais le scandale
est
si je pouvais le dire en hurlant je le
dirai en hurlant le scandale est que cet
argent nous ne l'avons pas nous
l'empruntons tous les ans c'est une très
grosse très importante partie de la
dette que nous contractons tous les ans
ce qui signifie que pour payer les
pensions des retraités actuels on charge
la barque des générations actives et des
plus jeunes
qui eux vont être obligés non seulement
de payer les retraites de leur
contemporain mais de payer plusieurs
décennies après plusieurs années ou
décennies après les retraites de ce qui
sont déjà à la retraite vous croyez ça
dans une famille mais vous voyez dans
une a du mal à passer on va revenir mais
du mal à passer
et puis je vous promets qu'après je
me tais voilà
vous imaginez dans une famille
que pour le train de vie des parents on
emprunte sur le compte des enfants c'est
ça qu'on est en train de faire il aurait
peut-être fallu l'expliquer en ces
termes parce que
Dieu sait que j'ai essayé de faire
prévaloir ce point de vue et
l'importance de cette information à
partager avec les français pour revenir
au syndicat et à l'Inter syndical et
relation avec l'exécutif il ne semble
plus avoir aucun contact
il y a eu cette demande de rencontre
avec le président de la République fin
de non-recevoir est-ce que vous auriez
répondu favorablement à la demande des
syndicats d'être heureux je ne suis pas
président de la République est-ce que
vous auriez conseillé au chef de l'État
et donc je
et donc
je pense que le Président de la
République est extrêmement conscient de
ceci
notre démocratie ne va pas bien et notre
démocratie sociale ne va pas bien non
plus le la place qui devait être reconnu
au représentant
des salariés des indépendants des
entreprises dans le travail qu'ils ont à
faire ensemble en France ça va pas du
tout
et quand on leur confie les
responsabilités ça va très bien
vous savez bien qu'il y a un régime de
retraite du privé qui s'appelle
Agirc-Arrco
qui est à l'équilibre
pour lequel les syndicats et le patronat
et les indépendants ont fait ensemble
l'effort nécessaire pour équilibrer le
régime mais on comprend
et ça marche très bien si vous dites la
démocratie sociale ne fonctionne pas
alors est-ce qu'il fallait justement
c'est ce que demande les syndicats plus
les maîtres au cœur des discussions et
les recevoir encore non il fallait
prendre la démocratie
sous un autre angle que celui que nous
avons l'habitude d'utiliser en France
depuis très longtemps
moi je plaide pour une démocratie de
pleine exercice dans laquelle on
considère que les citoyens
sont co-responsables des décisions que
nous devons prendre ensemble c'est à
dire qu'on leur donne tous les éléments
d'information ce que je viens d'exposer
devant vous et que personne ne peut
contredire personne ne peut prétendre
que les dizaines de milliards que nous
ajoutons pour l'équilibre du système de
retraite on les a
personne ne peut prétendre que c'est
normal une attribution normale du budget
de l'État et personne ne peut dire en
France alors vous reconnaîtrez là une
des antiennes que j'ai défendu à temps
et à contretemps personne ne peut dire
que notre niveau de dette est acceptable
depuis des années nous avons accepté que
les générations
actuelles vivent à crédit sur le dos des
plus jeunes et bien ceci normalement
n'est pas acceptable alors vos
démonstrations et vos arguments font
réagir sur les réseaux sociaux avec le
hashtag legrangeri Marie keradade on
réagir notamment Muriel sur Twitter qui
dit qu'il y a effectivement une base de
la contestation mais ne fait pas le même
la même conclusion que vous elle dit que
ça n'empêche pas le fait que les
Français restent contre la réforme des
retraites une majorité en tout cas elle
dit avez-vous réfléchi à la perte de
salaire qui peut être une des raisons
pour lesquelles les gens se mobilisent
moins est-ce que vous estimez vous avez
entendu est-ce que vous estimez qu'il
faut mettre en place un référendum pour
justement écouter les Français et les
appeler à choisir vous avez entendu que
je n'ai pas prononcé de mots péjoratif
pour ceux qui manifestent quand au
référendum si vous reprenez les
campagnes présidentielles que j'ai
défendues devant vous ou devant vos
prédécesseurs il y avait chaque fois
l'idée que la réforme des retraites
serait plus acceptée elle était adoptée
par référendum parce que ça oblige à
informer le pays les citoyens dans leur
profondeur des décisions qu'on prend
est-ce qu'il a dit que vous dites que
certains appellent aussi au référendum
il faut y aller ils y viennent en ultime
recours or c'est pas la démarche c'est
pas c'est pas la logique qui a été
choisie tout le monde a choisi une
logique parlementaire bon c'est pas du
tout la même logique que celle-là donc
c'est trop tard pour ça on est engagé
sur une autre voix alors sur justement
sur laquelle vous êtes engagés il y a
pas eu d'adoption à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a eu un vote bloqué et
unique c'était cette nuit au Sénat le
49-3 c'est-à-dire une adoption de la loi
sans vote est-il inéluctable non pas du
tout si je devais dire mon sentiment
je crois que le gouvernement n'a pas
envie de 49-3
l'impression que j'ai ou l'intuition que
j'ai
je peux me tromper mais l'intuition que
j'ai c'est que
le gouvernement n'a pas envie la
première ministre n'a pas envie de
passer à prendre le risque de passer au
49-3 alors deux observations moi j'ai
jamais considéré que le 49-3 était
honteux
Michel Rocard a dû l'utiliser 40 fois et
j'étais à cette époque là dans
l'opposition donc une opposition amicale
une opposition
respectueuse et correspondable mais
j'étais dans l'opposition il l'a utilisé
plusieurs dizaines de fois
j'ai jamais considéré que il y avait
quelque chose de mal dans le 49-3 mais
dans la situation où nous sommes et vous
avez raison de le dire par la situation
où nous sommes où le texte n'a pas été
adopté par un vote à l'Assemblée
nationale
alors je reconnais que les arguments
contre l'utilisation du 49.3 sont très
forts le Sénat d'ailleurs dans le JDD
qui dit que le 49-3 serait incroyable et
dangereux et constituerait une forme de
vice-démocratique à vous entendre
peut-être les mots sont un peu excessifs
acceptons que la polémique dans ces
moments-là se fasse entendre mais sur le
fond en effet un vote positif qui place
tout le monde devant ses responsabilités
je comprends que le gouvernement est
particulièrement la première ministre si
je me trompe pas
clairement vous êtes contre le recours
aux 49-3 je suis jamais contre une arme
institutionnelle mais dans l'état actuel
de cette de l'adoption de de cette
réforme des retraites je pense que la
première ministre a des raisons de de
choisir une autre voix mais est-ce qu'on
peut faire 149,3 aujourd'hui tout le
monde fait les comptes des députés a
priori ça passerait à 10 ou 12 voix à
l'assemblée tout le monde ça c'est vrai
et tout le monde s'aperçoit qu'il y a
peu de députés
c'est pourquoi aller à un vote positif
ça aurait de la gueule
si je puis m'exprimer
de manière aussi
à la roulette russe
pas jouer à la roulette russe et placer
chacun des parlementaires devant ses
responsabilités et si ça passe pas et
ben si ça passe pas on entre dans une
nouvelle phase une nouvelle période mais
quelle serait les séquences politiques
évidente c'est que ça ne
ça laisserait entier entier le problème
du déséquilibre des régimes de retraite
et que donc d'une manière ou d'une autre
qui que ce soit quel que soit
l'orientation dans la situation de nos
finances publiques ça va être dans la
honte qu'il y a surcharger les plus
jeunes des retraites en chantier et
immédiatement repartir sur une réforme
je pense que que c'est inéluctable et je
n'ai jamais rencontré jusqu'à maintenant
quelqu'un connaissant la réalité des
chiffres qui soutiennent le contraire on
peut dire la méthode n'était pas la
bonne il aurait fallu faire ceci ou cela
ou autrement moi-même
j'ai pu avoir des idées mais c'est pas
ça la question la question c'est que si
nous avons la moindre
le moindre souci de responsabilité pour
la cohésion des générations les
générations actuellement à la retraite
ne peuvent pas mettre le paiement de
leur pension sur le dos des actifs et
des plus jeunes si ça c'est ça serait
honteux mais sur le plan politique si
cette réforme était rejetée dans un vote
à l'Assemblée nationale pour vous ça
veut dire que démission de la première
ministre ça veut dire dissolution ça
veut dire vous savez il y a une règle
que je me suis fixé depuis longtemps je
ne commente pas les hypothèses
négatives les hypothèses du pire parce
que si vous venez devant votre micro de
mission
majeure avec des journalistes de tout
premier plan si vous venez dire voilà ce
qui pourrait se passer si on avait un
accident si on sortait de la route si la
voiture rentrait dans un platane si si
ces données du crédit
à l'idée que on aurait un parlement qui
refuserait cette responsabilité
aujourd'hui parce que Emmanuel Macron
compte après cette réforme des retraites
lancé ou relancer son second quinquennat
s'il y a un vote négatif il y a quelque
chose qui s'arrête tout de suite et là
on est dans une situation politique
qu'il faut envisager
100 fois sur le métier remettez votre
ouvrage c'est une c'est une vieille une
vieille maxime bon 100 fois sur le
métier personne et je le dis aux
responsable syndicaux je le dis au plus
au plus hostile personne ne peut
soutenir l'idée qu'on peut en rester
dans cette situation là
si on soulève une forme de contradiction
dans ce que vous dites aussi vous dites
que il n'y a rien de honteux et que
c'est une arme constitutionnelle à
utiliser de 49,3 et en même temps vous
parlez d'hypothèse du pire quand on
l'évoque j'adore j'adore les
journalistes
si je vous avais dit là on va utiliser
le 49.3 vous diriez monsieur Berrou vous
vous rendez compte il y a pas eu de vote
est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas que c'est
une atteinte démocratique profonde et là
je vous dis qu'il me semble que il y a
des raisons pour qu'on ne prenne pas des
raisons solides pour qu'on prenne pas le
cas en 9-3 et vous me dites vous
intéresse responsable de pas vouloir
prendre bon c'est le jeu c'est le jeu
surtout non mais je dis ça sans aucun
esprit
désagréable
on a on a besoin
d'affronter les responsabilités et donc
je et on les affrontera quoi qu'il se
passe on les affrontera l'idée que ça
serait du tout ou rien que que ça serait
fini est une idée absurde encore une
fois à la situation actuelle est
inacceptable c'est pas la seule
situation inacceptable du pays mais
celle-là l'est et comme c'est désormais
sur le métier sur le sur le chantier et
ben il faut aller au bout et son
courageux ceux qui affront toute cette
nécessité alors l'autre question et
j'aime bien le courage en politique
l'autre question c'est si la est-ce que
l'Assemblée nationale peut continuer
comme ça Marion oui alors on sait que
les contacts se multiplient entre
Elisabeth borne et la droite les
républicains Éric ciotique et le patron
des républicains affirment encore
aujourd'hui qu'il votera le texte est-ce
que à vos yeux la républicains sont des
partenaires fiables cette réforme des
retraites on a besoin de tout tous ceux
qui de bonne foi
considèrent que
la situation impose qu'on mène à son
terme une réforme des retraites sont des
partenaires fiables et c'est eux qui
vont décider en conscience mais les
parlementaires de la majorité aussi
vont devoir décider en conscience de
quel côté il se place et notamment par
rapport aux plus jeunes français quel
est le quel est le
au fond quel est le contrat d'un député
avec la nation c'est de s'occuper des
plus fragiles de ceux qui s'expriment
moins parce qu'ils sont plus jeunes de
ceux qui sont en activité ou qui le
seront cela ils ont pas de défenseur
évident alors c'est au parlementaire de
l'être mais est-ce que vous reprenez la
l'avertissement j'ai envie de dire de
d'Aurore berger la présidente du groupe
Renaissance ceux qui dans la majorité
majorité relative ne vote pas pour la
réforme des retraites seront exclues
de manier lucase et les relations que au
mouvement démocrates au modem nous avons
entre responsable politique et groupe ne
sont pas de cet ordre là c'est c'est
on essaie de ce qu'on vaincre
tout le monde réfléchit et réfléchit
dans un climat de
d'assez profond de amitié et solidarité
la méthode n'est pas la bonne du coup
celle d'Aurore berger
[Musique]
dans
le tableau et les députés les
républicains c'est assez étonnant quand
même on finalement fait pencher la
réforme plus à gauche avec pas mal de
mesures les 64 ans les 1200 euros les
carrières longues est-ce que finalement
la droite qui se retrouve plus à gauche
que le bloc central et ce qui m'a
Emmanuel Macron n'a-t-il pas mis le
paysage politique un peu sans dessus
dessous dans cette histoire je partage
en rien ce genre de jugement je ne sais
pas par excusez-moi je ne sais pas
devant une réforme de cet ordre ce que
veut dire droite et ce que veut dire
gauche je et comme vous savez j'ai
récusé ces notions toute ma vie
je me suis battu il y avait des
positions
pour pour que pour que ces notions
arrêtent de stériliser le débat national
en France nous avons une obligation une
c'est faire en sorte que notre système
de retraite nos régimes de retraite
retrouve je dirais d'ici à 10 ans
peut-être d'ici à 12 ans je j'ai la
responsabilité du plan et pour moi c'est
du moyen terme
d'ici à 12 ans un équilibre qui fasse
que le système redevienne réellement par
répartition c'est-à-dire que ce soit les
actifs qui assurent la charge des
pensionnés
Carco que je citais le système du privé
ils ont trouvé cet équilibre partenaire
sociaux en tête ils ont trouvé cet
équilibre ils ont eu le courage
et pour une raison que peut-être en
souligne pas assez c'est que ça s'est
fait progressivement
le
défaut de nos institutions en général
c'est que on va d'un coup en un coup de
choc en choc de d'affrontement en
affrontement au lieu d'avoir une
adaptation permanente
qui fasse que
oui on est capable de mettre le pays à
l'heure
réel
sans tout mettre par terre est-ce que
avec cette réforme des retraites on
n'est pas en train d'assister à ce que
Nicolas Sarkozy prônait une sorte de
contrat de gouvernement entre la
majorité présidentielle et la droite
je crois absolument pas ça mais
peut-être ça va se faire on verra
l'influence des uns et des autres
je ne crois pas que des députés élus
dans l'opposition
vont passer dans la majorité
peut-être quelques-uns
mais je ne crois pas que que
je pense qu'on peut avoir des
discussions comme vous dites un contrat
mais pas entrer à pas
abandonner l'engagement qu'on prend
devant les électeurs je crois pas
peut-être ça va se faire je serais
content de venir devant vous et de dire
je m'étais trompé je ne le sens pas
comme ça je crois que
LR à son identité et veut la conserver
je pense que le centre a son identité et
veut la conserver je pense que les
sociaux-démocrates de gauche ont leur
identité et veulent la conserver je ne
suis pas pour le melting pot je sais pas
pour tout mélanger je suis pour qu'on
puisse avoir une
correspondabilité une coopération qui
est encore une droite et une gauche
de décrire il y a une droite une gauche
et un centre parce que si vous si vous
si vous entrez à nouveau dans cette
obsession selon laquelle il n'y a que
deux angles pour appréhender la réalité
alors je vais vous renvoyer à la
photographie en noir et blanc il y a
aussi heureusement heureusement depuis
très longtemps on est passé à la
photographie en couleur il y a plusieurs
approches et la principale vertu
de l'engagement au centre c'est que nous
sommes les défenseurs du pluralisme et
on dit vous n'êtes pas obligé d'être
ficelé d'être enchaîné d'un côté ou de
l'autre vous avez la liberté d'imaginer
des voies nouvelles ça c'est le
pluralisme et le centre et le garant du
pluralisme et bien écoutez on parlera de
ces questions là et notamment de la
majorité ou c'est quand même toujours un
petit peu agité en ce moment on parlera
également d'inflation d'endettement du
pays et aussi du prochain projet de loi
qui sera compliqué également celui de la
loi immigration ça sera dans la seconde
partie de ce grand jury avec François
Bayrou à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exotisme douceur et frissons des
vacances
[Musique]
c'est tous ensemble que l'on peut agir
pour l'environnement rejoignez les
quatre millions de clients engie qui ont
fait le choix des offres d'électricité
verte et pour votre contrat de gaz optez
pour l'option gaz vert plus et
choisissez jusqu'à 100% de gaz vert
certifié produit en France j'agis avec
engie
[Musique]
envie de laisser votre budget vous
emmenez plus loin cet été découvrez
jusqu'au vous pouvez partir avec kayak
nous avons sélectionné nos meilleures
offres de billets d'avion vers des
destinations tendances en Europe et
au-delà consultez nos prix surprenants
pour Rome Majorque ou encore New York
laissez-vous inspirer rendez-vous sur
KAYAK
de nos jours ça fait du bien d'avoir une
bande qui vous offre autant de services
pour seulement 5 euros par mois
avec Hello Bank profitez de 80 euros
plus 6 premiers mois offerts des
difficultés avec l'anglais au travail
oui avec Babel apprenez une longue
rapidement grâce à des leçons
interactives basés sur des situations
réelles
la méthode qui marche pour apprendre des
langues téléchargez l'application ou
rendez-vous sur babel.com
j'adore chez vous merci
four electroluxe
vous arrêtez et oui Darty fait aussi des
cuisines avec hachoir incomparable de
cuisine et d'électroménager et en plus
la pose de votre cuisine est offerte
l'allure souvent ça ne tient à rien mais
ça fait toute la différence
en ce moment roulez surclassé avec le
Peugeot 3008 finition Allure
[Musique]
tout a commencé en soirée chez une amie
tu peux me l'envoyer bien sûr on
arrêtait pas de me demander
vraiment tout le temps
[Musique]
c'est pas une blague et toi
et vraiment tout le monde bien sûr avec
les nouveaux Galaxy S23 c'est le moment
de vous équiper jusqu'à 150 € remboursé
sur les galaxies Watch et les bugs
[Musique]
l'allure souvent ça ne tient à rien mais
ça fait toute la différence
en ce moment rouler surclassé avec le
Peugeot 3008 finition Allure
parier c'est se donner rendez-vous à 18h
pour un match à 21h
c'est débattre sur un match où personne
ne tombera d'accord
et finalement valider son pari quelques
minutes avant le coup d'envoi et si
Paris c'était plus que perdre gagner
Parions Sport nous sommes les parieurs
Direct Assurance bonjour mais vous
trouvez ça normal de nous faire
économiser 240 euros mais c'est
scandaleux monsieur non on va rester
chez vous c'est clair là ils ont compris
le seul risque avec une assurance qui en
fait autant pour vos économies c'est que
vous l'aimiez
[Musique]
c'est ça la magie du reconditionnement
par AramisAuto et le plus beau dans tout
ça c'est le prix qui restera toujours
d'occasion retrouvez des voitures
reconditionnées par des experts et
jusqu'à -30% sur AramisAuto.com
[Musique]
nous savons que vos vies ne rentrent
plus dans des cases mais nous sommes
toujours là pour les protéger CNP
Assurances assurant un monde plus ouvert
savez-vous comment haïr améliore votre
quotidien en proposant le mode de
cuisson idéal pour chaque recette votre
four connecté à Hyères s'adapte à un
style de vie exceptionnel de votre
ailleurs connecté à l'extraordinaire
[Musique]
en 2023 fécan le bonus écologique de
7000 euros à tous
[Musique]
l'entrée de Carson vous le voyez juste
derrière moi les fameux checkpoints de
passage militaires ont été resserrés il
est donc très difficile de les passer en
tant que journaliste demande maintenant
que nous éloigner car après cette frappe
tous redoutent et bien évidemment une
riposte de l'armée russe
il y a en ce moment même des combats
entre soldats russes et soldats
ukrainien
il faut arriver sur place les militaires
montrent que 15 secondes pour tirer
les Russes
le voyage
est à personne
[Musique]
suite du Grand Jury RTL le Figaro LCI
Olivier boste François Bayrou le
président du MoDem au commissaire-plan
et maire de Pau et notre invité pour ce
grand jury ce dimanche et nous allons
attaquer cette seconde partie avec un
sujet qui a fait énormément réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux toute la semaine
Marie Pirada oui semble que la tension
qui est provoquée par la réforme des
retraites touche tous les membres de
l'exécutif il y a eu les images vous
savez du fameux bras d'honneur d'Éric
Dupond-Moretti à l'Assemblée elles ont
tourné en boucle sur Twitter certains
internautes jugent que ce n'est pas
digne de son poste d'autres sont
beaucoup plus mitigés mais Gabriel Attal
lui dit croire Éric Dupont-Moretti quand
il dit que ça n'était pas adressé à un
parlementaire en particulier est-ce que
vous vous le croyez
je pense que l'ambiance qui règne à
l'Assemblée nationale porte à beaucoup
de
mots inacceptables et d'attitude qui ne
sont pas bien plus donc je pense que
c'est à cette question qu'il faut qu'on
faut qu'on s'attaque je pense que le les
conséquences ou les symptômes de cette
situation sont intéressantes mais c'est
laquelle c'est
lui-même de la première ministre du
président de la République je ne doute
pas qu'ils en aient parlé et qu'ils en
aient parlé je pense qu'il y a
peut-être on aura l'occasion d'en dire
un mot un peu plus tard
il y a un climat autour de la justice en
France
qui est qui porte
à des vagues de d'inquiétude parfois
d'exaspération
et je pense que le garde des sceaux qui
connaît la justice de l'Intérieur
parfois peut être aussi dans ce dans ce
type de sentiment là
la justice devrait devrait
faire naître un sentiment de justice et
pas un sentiment parfois d'injustice et
on devrait s'interroger tous ensemble
sur ce sujet là
et peut-être on aura l'occasion d'en
parler un peu plus tard on peut en
parler tout de suite puisque vous le
faites quand même des sous-entendus très
claires vous êtes vous serez
prochainement convoqué devant le
tribunal pour prochainement j'aimerais
bien mais je suis pas sûr il y a
effectivement pas de date en tout cas
vous êtes renvoyé devant le tribunal
pour une affaire c'est l'emploi de
d'assistant parlementaire européen payé
par le Parlement européen qui ont été
qui ont été utilisés pour votre partie
le modem ils ont travaillé pour pour le
modem comment vous réagissez à ce renvoi
devant le tribunal alors c'est une
affaire qui dure depuis six ans
et c'est une affaire qui au fil des
moines n'a cessé de se dégonfler
jusque au moment où nous sommes où
on ne voit plus quelle est la substance
du dossier c'est pour ça que vous
parliez d'injustice à l'instant
je vais essayer de vous dire ce que je
pense vraiment
et donc
on est accusé on a été accusé avec des
centaines d'articles dans les journaux
peut-être milliers d'articles dans les
journaux d'avoir monté un système pour
faire travailler des assistants
parlementaires pour le parti politique
je dis au passage
que nous ne l'avons pas fait essayer de
le prouver et deuxièmement que j'ai
jamais compris ce qu'il y avait de
honteux dans cette affaire mais
pardonnez-moi bien
le renvoie au tribunal quand même dit
que le décideur et le responsable de la
mise en place et du fonctionnement du
système frauduleux c'est vous et ben
vous allez en juger vous-même
avec des éléments qui sont indiscutables
donc tout le monde a lu qui avait des
sommes astronomiques et des responsables
de notre mouvement éminent qui sont plus
là comme Marielle de Sarnez qui était la
numéro 2 du mouvement et
qui était organisateur de tout ça dans
détournement d'argent public qui avait
pratiqué eux-mêmes un détournement
d'argent public tout cela écoutez-moi
bien a disparu du dossier
c'est à dire que Marielle de Sarnez a
été innocenté là cette semaine
sylvie Goulard a été innocenté Nathalie
grisbeck a été innocenté aucun de nos
parlementaires actuel ou de vous ou de
la législature précédente et moi j'étais
pas député européen et si vous imaginez
que
ma préoccupation on parle d'IA 17 ans ou
15 ans que ma préoccupation quand
j'étais candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en 2007 était de
m'occuper des conditions de travail mais
votre conclusion
s'il vous plaît parce que pour une fois
que j'ai l'occasion de défendre les
choses si vous vous imaginez qu'à cette
époque
confronté à l'élection majeure du pays
il était de ma responsabilité où j'avais
même l'idée de m'intéresser en quoi que
ce soit à la situation d'un assistant
parle mentaire à temps partiel
il y a 15 ans ou 17 ans alors c'est que
je suis je suis sûr vous vous n'avez pas
une idée exacte de la situation en
vérité de cette affaire là il ne reste
rien et ça sera prouvé
cas par cas comme nous l'avons prouvé
cas par cas jusqu'à maintenant vous avez
tous lu que tous lui écrit c'est souvent
que le préjudice estimait de cette
rocambolesque à faire était de 1 million
400 000 euros il reste aujourd'hui
260000 euros vous avez appliqué sur sur
Twitter vous avez fait une série tweets
pour expliquer tout ça vous dites il ne
reste aujourd'hui que quelques je vous
lis 300.000 euros sur douze années et
les réponses des internautes à ce
commentaire là vous disent quand même
300000 euros c'est une somme assez
colossale pour nous
parce que on confond une organisation et
un foyer ça représente cette somme là
260 ou 300.000 euros sur 12 ans ça
représente moins écoutez bien moins de
2% de la masse salariale du parti
politique qu'il a investi pendant toute
cette période et moins de 1/2 % de la
totalité de ses charges donc vous dites
c'est une affaire pour pas grand-chose
pour résumer les affaires pour pas grand
chose
vous savez je me suis posé pendant toute
cette période qui était à bien des
égards comme vous le comprenez tragique
je me suis posé une seule question
si vous n'avez pas le cuir épais
tenez par des décennies d'attaque
si vous n'avez pas un minimum de moyens
avocats
si vous n'avez pas comme nous l'avons
fait garder des centaines de milliers de
documents
pour faire la preuve de ce que vous
avancez et si vous pouvez pas venir
devant un micro pour vous défendre
comment résistez vous à ce rouleau
compresseur mais vous avez des mots qui
ont marqué Marielle de Sarnez vous avez
dit il y a un mois Marielle de sarnaise
est morte à cause de ses accusations
est-ce que vous n'allez pas trop loin
ni ses enfants ni ses proches ni ses
amis n'ont jamais eu le sentiment que
c'était allé trop loin que de dire la
vérité alors bon c'est des machines
il y a quelque chose de Kafka dans cette
affaire là
ça s'arrête jamais vous pouvez jamais
défendre un point de vue
parce que venir derrière un micro pour
dire mais attendez il y a 15 ans donc en
2005 ou 2006 monsieur enfin Madame une
telle qui était secrétaire elle
travaillait pas à ça elle travaille à
impossible vous avez une explication à
l'attitude des juges alors parce que
j'ai largement en cause la justice je ne
suis pas complotiste
je vis j'observe comme tout le monde
naturellement que
ça semble ressortir à intervalles
réguliers n'est-ce pas que que
c'est comme ça c'est comme c'est comme
des des cycles ça fleurit très
complotistes mais pas
naïf oui je j'ai quelques idées de la
manière dont tout ça est né mais après
c'est une machine qui est en route et
pour reprendre l'expression
et c'est une machine
permettez-moi de le dire
on pourrait vivre avec elle s'il y avait
le secret de l'instruction
il y a pas de secret de l'instruction la
présomption d'innocence n'existe pas
c'est pour ça que je crois que le garde
des sceaux
se manifestait comme ça avec des bras
d'honneur la présomption d'innocence
n'existe pas le secret de l'instruction
n'existe pas les journalistes ont les
documents de justice avant que les
justiciables même ne les reçoivent
François vaillerault est-ce que vous
avez est-ce que vous avez envisagé de
démissionner le temps que cette affaire
passe en vitesse et c'est l'une des
questions qu'on vient de recevoir vous
avez compris que que c'est exactement ce
que je disais nous sommes innocents
cette affaire n'a pas eu lieu
pour ceux qui sont entrés dans ce genre
de système j'ai jamais compris en quoi
c'était moralement répréhensible ça a
été juridiquement peut-être mais nous ne
l'avons pas fait alors quelqu'un qui
voudrait
me faire entrer dans ce genre de
considération pour quelque chose dont je
sais avec certitude que ça n'a pas eu
lieu celui-là n'est pas né vous dites ça
revient régulièrement est-ce que c'est
en rapport avec vos ambitions politiques
et le fait que régulièrement vous vous
disiez notamment par exemple que 2027
rien n'est exclu
je
soupçonne parfois des forces occultes
mais là franchement quelqu'un qui
voudrait m'agresser pour 2027
je ne crois pas une seconde à tout ça je
crois pas au complot je crois au
mécanique je crois à Kafka je crois que
vous êtes dans dans un système et
combien de justiciables vivent ça je
vous ai expliqué les atouts que nous
avions les autres ils les ont pas
que si j'avais pas gardé des centaines
de milliers de documents comment je
pourrais faire la preuve qu'en 2005
tel secrétaire
je les connaissais même pas
c'est
c'est une affaire devant laquelle vous
vous trouvez vous justiciable et ça peut
arriver à tout le monde tous ceux qui
sont ici totalement désarmés
on a communiqué cette semaine comme vous
l'avez dit
il y a eu une ordonnance de renvoi
devant un tribunal un jour on sait pas
quand
personne n'a dit ce que ce que je vous
ai dit c'est à dire que
l'immense majorité des charges ont
disparu
la justice a reconnu que ces charges
n'existaient pas n’étaient pas
justifiées que c'était infondé
c'est-à-dire exactement ce que je dis
depuis le 1er jour de cette affaire il
n'est pas vrai qu'il y a eu le moindre
système de détournement de quoi que ce
soit on a entendu vos explications sur
ce sujet
et pour être revenir vraiment à la
politique politicienne pour le coup
une parenthèse sur le sur l'avenir du
macronisme le bloc central constitué par
Emmanuel Macron est-il aujourd'hui assez
solide pour suivre vivre à Emmanuel
Macron en 2027 je vous pose la question
parce qu'on voit que entre les
partenaires autour d'Emmanuel Macron
avec horizon le parti démorph-philippe
avec le vôtre le modem ça semble aussi
de plus en plus compliqué par moment
notamment à l'Assemblée nationale alors
pour moi à la question ce blog central
est-il assez solide pour résister aux
étapes qui viendront inéluctablement
ma réponse est oui
et non seulement il est assez solide
mais il faut qu'il le soit
c'est une vous avez compris
j'ai un engagement
de plusieurs décennies dans la vie
politique française cet engagement il
s'est constitué autour d'une certitude
c'est que on n'était pas obligé de
tomber dans l'affrontement bipolaire
systématique entre droite et gauche
on voit aujourd'hui ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment on en a
fait réellement la démonstration parce
que nous avons gagné l'élection
présidentielle avec
on a gagné les législatives pas à la
majorité absolue mais à la majorité
relative et de très loin de très loin on
a gagné deux fois une présidentielle
deux fois une élection législative et il
reste naturellement à consolider
ce bloc central c'est-à-dire
semaine et vous devez notamment réunir
sur la photo prochainement et accueillir
justement est-ce qu'il y a besoin d'une
photo de famille pour montrer que tout
le monde reste une je voudrais mettre en
garde contre quelque chose
c'est l'idée que à l'intérieur
de ce bloc central vital pour l'avenir
du pays
se reconstitue un droite contre gauche
que ça
c'est pas du tout le projet que vous
décrivez c'est l'éclatement du bloc
central c'est pas du tout le projet je
dis ceci parce que parfois je lis des
choses ici ou là
ceci n'est pas dans la nécessaire
philosophie dont on a besoin pour
affronter l'avenir
je répète le centre c'est pas seulement
le centre c'est la garantie du
pluralisme pour tout le monde
ça veut dire que vous n'êtes pas obligé
de vous inféodez à un côté ou à l'autre
comme on a été obligé de le faire
pendant 30 ans mais pour reprendre les
propos de quelqu'un que vous connaissez
très bien Jean-Louis borlange il dit que
le problème des élus Renaissance
aujourd'hui c'est qu'ils ne savent pas
quel est leur chef pour 2027 est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous reprenez à
votre compte est-ce que le groupe est
perdu je n'ai je ne n'ai pas de doute
que ces questions se poseront ce
traiteront j'espère se trancheront mais
la première chose à avoir en tête c'est
la philosophie de ce que nous faisons
nous refusons que tout dans la vie
démocratique se résume à un affrontement
que cette violence là tu es d'un côté ou
de l'autre cité de l'autre tu es un
mauvais français et ça n'est pas
possible que on te confie c'est pas ça
notre philosophie à nous c'est que nous
sommes
co-responsables de l'avenir la
démocratie de co-responsabilité celle
dans laquelle vous êtes syndicaliste
vous êtes patronat vous êtes opposant où
vous êtes majoritaire vous êtes rien du
tout vous avez une responsabilité
équivalente sur l'avenir du pays pas la
même mais équivalentes et ceux-ci qui
s'appelle au fond c'est c'est le grand
courant réformiste du pays ce grand
courant là il demande à vivre à être
reconnu et à être incarné vous parliez
de risque d'affrontements il y aura des
risques d'affrontement sur le plan
politique avec un prochain projet de loi
Marion Maury peut-être avec la réforme
des retraites et passer à l'immigration
à un autre texte arrive au Sénat porté
par Gérald Darmanin est-ce que pour vous
ça vous semble utile en ce moment cette
période qui est un peu agitée et
qu'est-ce que vous demandez à ce texte
aujourd'hui comme vous dites en ce
moment il va falloir affronter toutes
les questions même les plus difficiles
celle-là est difficile mais il va
falloir l'affronter pourquoi parce qu'il
y a une inquiétude profonde chez
beaucoup de Français une grande partie
du peuple français qui a des inquiétudes
sur son identité
et comme on en a déjà parlé ensemble
depuis des années j'ai essayé de
formuler cette question là
pour moi c'est pas une question de race
ça n'est pas une question de religion
c'est une question d'un patrimoine
commun que nous avons à
identifier et à faire vivre mais est-ce
que le texte de Gérald Darmanin prend en
compte ça cette
et puis le débat va nous éclairer mais
les questions d'identité sont des
questions de vie ou de mort
ça paraît bizarre
mais le les êtres humains ne peuvent pas
vivre sur les prives de leur identité
ça veut dire que pour les groupes
humains n'ont plus les communautés
humaines ont besoin qu'on les
reconnaisse dans une identité et elles
ont besoin d'être certaine de ceci qui
est assez délicat à exprimer
que leur genre de vie elles vont pouvoir
le transmettre donc pour préserver pour
préserver l'identité il faut stopper
l'immigration que notre j'ai pas dit ça
analyse bah non je n'ai absolument pas
dit ça que leur valeur vont pouvoir être
transmises et il y a une immigration qui
respecte les valeurs du pays mais quand
vous voyez la proposition de Gérald
Darmanin de donner des titres de séjour
à des gens qui viendraient travailler en
France dans les métiers en tension
est-ce que pour vous c'est la porte
ouverte vous la prouvez ce n'est pas la
porte ouverte pour vous des arrivées
massives quelqu'un qui arrive en France
et qui je m'exprime ma petite
personnelle comme vous comprenez
quelqu'un qui arrive en France
qui
respecte le pays où il trouve
une nouvelle vie ou une nouvelle étape
de vie
qui fait l'effort d'en apprendre la
langue
et qui s'insère en particulier par le
travail
pas parler de public mais par le travail
celui-là a et aura
si ce que je crois se fait entendre sa
place dans le pays mais dans quelle
proport c'est pas une question de peau
ensuite où il faut alors la question de
proportion est très importante
quand dans un village vous mettez une ou
deux familles venus d'une autre culture
quel que soit la culture ça se passe
très bien et quand dans un village vous
mettez des dizaines de familles un petit
village des dizaines de familles ça se
passe mal il y a une question de
proportion de proportion et d'équilibre
parce que c'est la partie humanité qui
est votre Marion mais aussi toute la
partie fermeté du texte est-ce que vous
ne craignez pas qu'il ne reste que cette
partie là notamment avec des méthodes
parce que je pense que le Parlement
fera entendre un certain nombre de
nécessité mais vous voyez on présente
toujours ça comme si c'était des
questions de race de religion de peau de
c'est pas vrai je vais prendre un
exemple Mayotte
Mayotte il y a d'un mouvement assez
profond de rejet très profond de rejet
violent qu'on pourrait qualifier même de
racisme or
c'est les mêmes origines
c'est la même religion
c'est la même langue et ce sont les
mêmes familles mais les familles venues
des Comores dans cette île des Comores
qui est Mayotte la société mahoraise la
rejette de manière extrêmement violente
et c'est le cas en Guadeloupe je regarde
maxorville qui est au fond de la salle
et en Martinique parfois en Guadeloupe
ça a été très violent ça a été un
mouvement extrêmement violent c'est le
cas
en Guyane le chaque fois que vous
déstabilisez une société
sans qu'il y ait même besoin de
questions de race
par un non respect des proportions
acceptables ou souhaitable alors vous
faire vous faites naître du racisme un
dernier mot avant la fin de cette
émission François Bayrou est-ce que vous
croyez encore à une réforme des
institutions est-ce que vous avez des
nouvelles de la commission
transpartisane qui avait annoncé
Emmanuel Macron sur le sujet d'abord moi
j'étais tout à fait partisan d'une
commission transpartisane dans laquelle
les partis politiques essaient de se
faire entendre
de cette commission on verra si c'est le
si c'est le cas ou pas
si quelqu'un vient dans cette émission
et Eddy la démocratie française ça
marche très bien le Parlement ça marche
très bien on est vraiment content parce
que moi on discute on se respecte si
celui-là existe je vous demande de
l'amener sur le plateau le plus personne
aujourd'hui en France qui puisse être
fier de ce qui se passe au Parlement
la proportionnelle dans les deux
chambres un peu moins au Sénat à
l'Assemblée mais on a vu aussi des
scènes des tensions
on peut pas vivre comme ça une
démocratie ne peut pas vivre sans
institution respectée donc il faut des
changements mais ça serait pas encore
plus le bazar avec la proportionnelle
par exemple mais la proportionnelle on y
est le résultat de la proportionnelle
alors
parlementaires qui sont dans le studio
souris parce que moi je pense qu'il faut
changer le règlement de l'Assemblée
nationale je pense qu'il faut adopter
des des règles de vie qui nous
permettent de de ne pas avoir
systématiquement des injures des
des gestes déplacés de toutes cette
affaire là je pense que c'est une
réforme de très grande ampleur et
qu'elle est très difficile à conduire
parce que les institutions sont
construites pour ne pas pouvoir être
changé merci beaucoup François
merci à tous et à dimanche prochain
[Musique]